[Music]
Ansel Adams was our country's most
brilliant landscape photographer
unfortunately most people could only
enjoy Adams photography in large
inconvenient coffee-table books until
now presenting the complete works of
Ansel Adams as an audio book read by
emmy-winning actor James Gandolfini
you'll be transported to the American
West with Gandolfini's vivid
descriptions of Adams most memorable
works okay well we got here looks like a
curvy road a bunch of mountains not bad
nice picture
what's this some kind of Brook Creek or
some a bunch of fancy rocks do I know
and unlock the sexual mysteries of the
illustrated Kama Sutra okay this one's
called the alpine mishap looks like
they're riding on a snowmobile
now the lady's got a hand on the
throttle and your children's favorite
pop-up books come to life okay it's here
to make froggy jump in here pull his tab
come on you mother the james gandolfini
audiobook collection you can say this is
a terrible idea but really is it any
worse than our collection of Shaquille
O'Neal's Sudoku puzzle audiobooks
three babies no way out of six
[Applause]